[Musik]
ich möchte dass nämlich ankündigte
wollen darum die echt jetzt ja müsste
mindestens und andere planeten noch ok
hallo herzlich willkommen so sli fällt
ich habe mir gedacht weil der lette
nächste woche nicht letzte mal war der
nächste woche valentinstag ist machen
wir doch was schönes besonderes
natürlich mache ich dieses video nicht
alleine sondern ich brauche eine war
einfach kompetenten partner an meiner
seite
ja noch mal machen schuldig ich habe mir
gedacht habe du ganz kurz und so hat man
ganz kurze ich mich jetzt gerade in
diesem moment auch bei frau merkel
bedanken weil wir männer dieses jahr
valentinstag und so eigene frau war
diesmal glaubt dass nur männer an
valentinstag ein außer geschäftstermin
haben außer haus er schaut sich
gewöhnlich dankeschön ja valentinstag
ein riesenthema
die leute die mich schon seit sieben
jahren kennen wissen dass ich da voll
ausführt valentinstag kommt total gut
weil sie seit 2007 rasch mir auch was
schönes geschenk geburtstag muttertag
was gibt es alles hochzeitstag
frauenbild frauen haben weltfrauentag
der tag an dem ich meine frau
kennengelernt habe an dem sie mit ganzen
immobilien überschrieben hat alles tage
wo ich jeden tag frei und kann
es ist echt der wahnsinn ich ja damals
gedacht weil wir eigentlich schon so auf
instagram das vorzeige romantik ehepaar
sind immer und es schafft sie hat sich
lieb dich genau und dann machen wir so
unser liebes kosten
ich habe eigentlich schöne bilder gaben
sie das einzige dem händchen halten ich
glaube wir sind das einzige partei ist
ob instagram kein einziges mit einem
sieben jahren gemacht wo es ein bisschen
verliebt aus sieht ja ja ja ganz ehrlich
als ich
es läuft ja falls es läuft ja man muss
es nicht immer der ganzen welt zeigen
treiben und comedy auf wie oft kam es
von vor
wir haben auch freunde und bekannte
wurde dann noch so ein tag vorher mensch
hat ohne dich und am nächsten tag
scheidung muss und außerdem muss ich
ehrlich sagen meine mutter schaut zu und
ich will sie nicht irgendwie verstören
brauchen des überschusses gelogen hat
übertreiben okay jedenfalls habe ich mir
gedacht wir machen pralinen als zeichen
der liebe soll dieses paar lieder wir
machen so liebes prämien und zwar es hat
nichts mit amore oder videos oder sollst
du dich selber aphrodisierend also das
haus aphrodisierende zutaten reichen ja
wir machen annehmen bei dir bitte netz
der schon weiß ja um eure partnerschaft
nicht auf eine probe zu stellen sondern
um eure partnerschaft noch emotionaler
und tiefgründiger zu machen und macht
doch einfach diesen pralinen kurs
zusammen wurde heute wie netflix aber ja
und ich denke wenn ihr die parallel und
zusammen schafft dann schafft ihr alles
im leben komm wir fangen jetzt an wir
haben wenn man kollegen hohlkörper genau
dankeschön
damit gemeint ist jemand wie die
schokolade jetzt geradezu schaut sie
meine geschichte ist ein hohlkörper und
wir machen jetzt eine leckere füllung
normalerweise machen wir pralinen immer
mit so einer füllung oder mit trüffel
füllung also mit schokolade und sahne
ich habe mir jetzt aber gedacht wir
machen wir was leichteres und malen was
gelingen sicheres ja damit da kein er
streit gibt ja das ist wirklich jeder
hingehen und damit nur sagen dann weiß
ich ich würde es nicht unterbrechen aber
ihr könnt dieses jahr könnt ihr alles
eher zu also auch die die blume rhein wo
die tat sagen winkler ist eine floristin
und back nicht besser sondern die
gärtner genau ihr könnt trotzdem blumen
bestellen und sie abholen also der
valentinstag ist für die ganzen
floristen eingefasst der wichtigste tag
nach muttertag dh bestellt was bei euch
vor ort in gärtnereien und holt euch die
pflanzen ab ich habe es die letzten
jahre immer am friedhof gemacht hätte
da mache ich diesmal nicht mehr will ich
gerne wenn du die floristin so gerne
unterstützt warum haben alle gut kommen
wir fangen jetzt an
jedenfalls habe ich hier schon mal
zutaten gerichtet und du kannst ja noch
sagen was du gerne dazu hättest ja 100
gramm herbert das randtief gefordert
denn es ist ja gerade keine saison 200
gramm quark wir haben jetzt ihren
magerquark 50 gramm puderzucker 150
gramm frischkäse und 20 gramm
kokosraspeln okay oder willst du dir
nochmals eine zutat ja und kilogramm
rumpsteak mit bratkartoffeln ja ok magst
du vielleicht tonga oder vanilla dazu
ich will er tun kann ja mal passieren
ich glaube dass ich ab rotieren man darf
es aber nicht übertreiben muss ich ganz
ganz ehrlich sagen weil könnte die hose
und ok also das erste auswärts machen
die ich ihm werden
auftauen dass da geht es einfach um den
schulden selbst gleich auf misstrauen
also machen wir das nicht öfter ja ich
bin zwar ein heißer typ aber das war
hier kompakt so here's a der seien ganz
einfach zu binden der ist idiotensicher
dann wurde am gymi ausgetestet und alles
was beim wieder ausgebessert wird kann
jeder so menü mikrowelle 600
geht doch mehr auf den friseur was neuen
lippen habe ich also habe ich mir
aufgefallen jetzt hier deine hessen hin
werden wir haben jetzt drei ihr könnt es
nämlich alle zutaten einfach in den
mixer pürieren oder mit einem pürierstab
ist ganz ganz easy gemacht ok es müssten
was ein zu machen wie bei wie heißt der
film nochmal dirty dancing ist so ok
kommen alle zutaten kannst du denn da
war schon nicht träger das jetzt wohl
nicht mehr
ich habe so eine phobie gegen
abschlecken in der kritik
und ja und auf jeden fall versuchen wir
haben ja die zuschauer nach fragen
gestellt die kita st wir machen hier
grad noch das okay wir müssen erst kurz
vor ihren und einführt und dann war da
frage ich war so schnell also auf dem
leben so jetzt passiert
[Musik]
das riecht wohl nach friedhof
nein wirklich das ist irgendwie so
komisch mensch dann aber diesen so schön
auf jeden fall war es so wir haben
unsere zuschauer gefragt was haben sie
eigentlich fragt werden das tor gemacht
und haben gesagt wir machen heute dieses
video und stellt noch mehr fragen über
mich über morath und stellt dem rat
fragen wenn ich mich und dann muss ich
gucken ob ich die fragen über ihn
beantworten kann und er über wie genau
und ich habe sieben union fragen
gekriegt und ich suche mal aus dem
sieben millionen paar aus
ich hatte nie an absprachen sagt wir
fühlen erstein und dann machen die
fragen wären also wir fühlen scheinen
jetzt könnt ihr eine dosierte nehmen
oder nehmen einen spritzbeutel oder ein
johanna gefriert hüther geht auch und
klein trichter so ein mini trichter und
jetzt fühle ich dass hier ein
wir machen natürlich zwei flaschen denn
wir werden beide gießen
[Musik]
weiser voraussicht habe ich jetzt mal so
gemacht dass ich eine flasche etwas
voller gemacht habt in dem ich ja später
richtig cool
mir wäre jetzt eigentlich ganz recht ja
sogar machen wird schon später eine
million macht auch die knoblauch
gegessen
die machen mich traurig dass die
pflanzen optimal
[Applaus]
mal sehen ob das so jetzt müssen wir
einfach und dank kam washington schickt
einfach mal schnell geht aber ich
bräuchte erhöhte arbeitsplatte rang neun
menschen
warum hast du dich entschieden jetzt die
arbeit läuft noch sagte wir nehmen
einfach das okay wir haben jetzt hier
sagt peter schokolade vollmilch und weiß
was denkst du alles außer weiß ja ich
würde sogar sagen zartbitter
manchmal weiß ich es auch gleich warum
weil anbieter ist es bitter ist das war
nicht so süß und schokolade zu
destabilisieren
also gerade mit viel kakao gehalten als
ich nicht dass es nötig hätte schon
sonst nur sagen so und jetzt einführen
natürlich den partner arbeit können wir
so nicht so seine musik spielen aber es
geht eigentlich es gibt zwei oder wie es
gibt drei hammer sequenzen in fünf
videos also in filmen und zwar ist es
einmal bei titanic wenn der andere
league steht
[Musik]
dann gibt es noch die zweite filmsequenz
das ist bloß mit patrick swayze schweres
los
[Musik]
aber ein etwas schmuddelig wird oder
gibt es doch die dritte coole
filmsequenz und zwar bis ich bei mindjet
identisch wenn die wenn sie dann so
losgeht und erst dann so ich will sich
daran und ja wir sind die wirklichen
drei kannst du mich halt 39
doch wird es nicht dass man mich halt
mich an mächtig spricht nein mache jetzt
halt mich fest ja ich halte ich fest
dass die städte nicht okay lass das
lieber das funktioniere und fernsehen
gemerkt es auch diese drei finden sind
jetzt muss man kennen ja
[Musik]
und immer wenn wir zwei so liebe es
filme anschauen dann dann und es sich
morgens und die stehen morgens auf und
clubszene und ich war das ist so ich
hätte es so eklig ist es dank des der
nächsten bohr was geht es ja nicht nur
bei filmen steht erst morgen stehe ich
auch gut nach rechts und bestes und und
andere knoten sich das ist dann das ist
der wahnsinn hat jeder zähneputzen ja ok
weiter geht genau sagen da ist es
wichtig ist was nicht nach vorne feste
drücken sondern eher hinten halten
eigentlich ohne druck arbeiten weil es
hier raus so jetzt hier ein fühlen und
nicht ich hab ich habe es gerade mal
hast du merkt aber als beliebt gemacht
ja und so voll weil winterluft rené
charles gemerkt und es kann sich auch in
hohlkörper luft bilden also gerade hast
du nicht geredet über geschossen baby
ist nicht glaubt es gibt kann man jetzt
so eine erotische musik darunter lägen
also während wir das machen aber dann
muss ich mich auch sehr erotisch
angucken
[Musik]
wieso
guck nicht so voll und dann lieber
klopfen dann gucken wir wo sich setzt
und filmen so bis 8 und am rand ich
würde sagen dass diese musikrichtung ist
gröbsten ich weiß nicht ob man die
pflanzen waren es am friedhof hier und
umwelt kommt der knoblauchgeruch ich
weiß ich kann mich ja gar nicht so
wohlfühlen das irgendwie bekommen sogar
kann die stimmung aus im nächsten leben
ja heirat jemand wie du und fitness
model ja genau ich hinten links der
nächstes jahr also in meinem nächsten
leben heiraten fitness modell ein
fitness youtuber heirat ich der erste
wäre es komisch dass deine tasche buch
so jetzt habe ich erst ab 1 und 2 schon
geschafft kühe hergestellt pralinen
gefüllt und die kommen jetzt kurz ins
tiefkühlfach damit die füllung festwirt
und wir sie gleich beschließen kann
so können die kammer zeit jetzt habt ihr
auch zu hause genau jetzt kommen wir
fragen uns auch eine stunde ja er hat
auch eine stunde zeit
[Musik]
sollte jetzt selbst schauen oder bei den
fensterbänken helfen so und
währenddessen frage stellt sich jetzt
die frage
die zuschauer mich gestellt haben über
meine frau die ich beantworten muss
ich hoffe dass verstanden kleinen
hauptschülern also fragen vorlesen ja
schließlich fragen jetzt vor ok also
fangen wir an mit der ersten frage was
liebt sie am meisten an dir das muss
jetzt antworten und durchsage bestimmt
[Musik]
und dein humor okay wenn nur mit einem
ein meter großen blumenstrauß kommen
würde was würdest du sagen willst du
meine größe gemacht
das hätte ich mir gedacht aber ich hätte
gesagt was hast heute angestellt warst
du ihre große liebe wörsdorf ja ihre
große liebe war oder bin ich doch da
genau das bist du okay ist sie auch mal
was nicht so gesundes wenn die kamera
aus ist und alle mitarbeiter wechseln
oft richtig oft aber wir haben nun die
nächste frage streitet ihr auch mal oder
ist immer friede freude eierkuchen
eigentlich will das ja passen dass bei
uns immer friede freude eierkuchen ist
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
streiten sie oft legen also ich täglich
eigentlich meistens morgens mittags
abends streiten hier aber dann sagt sie
und stimmt doch gar nicht ich hatte auch
meistens weg ja so ist es einfach
weghören dann nicht mehr einfach weg und
zwar nächste frage hat sally jemals
versagt ja und zwar um 21 03 2008
was war da hans rauch zeit ja
es gibt manche fehler die begleitenden
das ganze leben ja und jetzt manche
leute heiraten fehler
hier sind sie dann welche pflegeserie
benutzt also keine pflegeserie also
schwingt man sowas und wahrscheinlich
keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht da schon
besser ich habe nicht wie lange braucht
sally morgens im bad braucht zehn und
für dieselben und 15 minuten die sachen
mit so räumt die ich dann wieder
schmutzig gemacht haben stimmt ja zum
beispiel hat sich schlechte
angewohnheiten die sie ablegen möchte
singen ja das singen wird sie gern
ablegen oder sollte sie normalerweise ab
liegen ja beide letzten karaoke haben
uns zu haben habe ich das singen gehört
habe ich da sollten wir ein dickes ding
heute wo es wäre zeit für einen lieb ist
wenn wir heute 1 machen dann werde ich
das liebesduett unserer weihnachtsfeier
2009 10 19 uhr damit blenden ist als
petition spalinger alle leute hier
nein unfall im monat die wollen doch
alle freude dann kommt dann kommt dann
frau merkel und deine impfstoff dagegen
entwickeln so kann z rückwärts und
seitwärts einfahren
sally carr rückwärts seitwärts und von
oben einfach glauben wir dass das kann
die längst alles stimmt jetzt nicht ich
kann es klein also sind keine reinpacken
kann sie wirklich denkt besser als du ja
muss aussagen geradeaus fahren wer würde
sich eher impfen lassen
ich glaub da die immobilien und mich
sind an der stopp zuerst starb aber eben
von uns stellen spricht man nicht
das gesetz ja okay das ist das große
social media gesetz wenn du eine
diskussion auslösen willst dann sag was
übers stillen oder über das impfen aber
nicht also ich bin jetzt mal still
okay aber richtig ding war sowieso tage
scheinen bereit
ja ja ja ja jetzt kannst du nicht okay
war so dass fragen ich weiß wo man den
füßen mit weil ich keine zeit das erste
ist keine frage sondern ich weiß schon
zu viel über ihn über mich wichtig
lehrer ralf das ist mein klassenlehrer
das ist der wahnsinn hat sie verfolgt
mich einfach mein leben lang mit mich
dazu holen
mein klassenlehrer ganz cool aktuell
noch als noch mal papa fragt hat murat
eigentlich unterarm implantate ja das
habe ich schon echt vor hallo ich über
antwort ja nein aber es gut die frage ob
martin oraze lieblingswort das hat
direkt gefragt moratz lieblingswort ist
genial wahnsinn und wahnsinn oder und so
so so so so so welches essen würde murat
niemals anrühren kürbis süßkartoffel
gesund außer ich hab's ungesund
verpacken dann noch meine band und
rheinbrücke wochen erkennt wann das
moratorium gerät ist also da muss man
gut beobachten können
er wird zudem das stimmt wirklich
der blutzucker sinkt meerfeld war strom
stuhl er fängt an hysterisch sachen zu
suchen und dann ist der persönlichkeiten
und das war er kann tatsächlich wenn er
wirklich hunger hat kann er
wir hatten immer früher hier so ein
stand der stecher am eingang der macht
schauen und dann steht schon da
der hand dabei hat er eine schauküche
heißt wir haben sie immer früher also 25
kohl weißt du für die ganze woche
und hast du dann erwischt man schauen
dass die schauküche daran liegen dass
sie vom stecher was was liebst du am cd
was lebt morath an mehr wissen ich habe
alles wissen also egal was du was war
sein erstes autor das weiß ich
tatsächlich nicht ich weiß nur dass ich
irgendwann mein allererstes auto wird
man irgendwann so ein bmw z3 nein habe
ich nicht sagt war es ja erst so was
kommt
jeder stich gelassen wenn alle aller
erstes auto muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
dass zurzeit ein 3er bmw gemietet hat
sein sagt doch so was ist glück wohl
denken jetzt nur das technisch verkäufer
und weil sie haben gemüse händen warum
mein erstes auto ganz ehrlich es war es
war neuwagen ist möchte ich mal die mit
18 neuwagen warum will ich schon ganz
ganz früh mit schwarz baustellen
angefangen habe und so war das auch fiat
seicento und gelbes auto geändert wie
die 8
und jetzt doch etwas erzähle ist voll
cool es ist aber stehen jetzt wirklich
das war ein fiat seicento und im
radkasten jetzt ungelogen ich weiß nicht
warum
ob es normal ist ein kondom betrieben
ich weiß nicht was mit dem was mit dem
ich stimmt aber es stand wirklich so war
es ist einfach das war einfach furchtbar
ich komme zu einer normalen frage was
ist seine lieblingsgruppe lieblingsmusik
gruppe gut entwickele sagte biskup also
zurzeit hersteller gern clueso und
clueso ja wie spricht man das aus kohle
so ich mache auch coldplay und so ich
mag powerplay ich mag braucht jetzt
deutsche musik mache ich ganz gesagt
solange sie nicht von florian
silbereisen von adoro sie hatte ein
deutscher musiker genau kannst du freund
sportfreunde stiller sportfreunde
stiller kompliment fanta 4
das ist genau meine zeit und beste musik
war ein paar ihren 90 und genau da haben
die jungs noch keine roten schuhe
getragen er eine rebsorte und was weiß
eben einmal coole musik ein bisschen
gitarre tan dun bank machen
wie geht mora täglich mit so viel
frauenpower um
tabletten wann ist mein geburtsdatum das
würde ich gerne durch die regierungs man
sich so august nein sommeranfang schon
seit 2008 219 108 119 109 80 88 89 89
nicht 88 und mein gott was ist sein
lieblingsbuch m
jetzt kommen ich hab mir der bibliothek
das mit dem mann mit den vielen bücher
man die leben gelesen als waren zwei
bilderbücher manns und einmal das
telefonbuch geheißen und es anderen
wirklich ein cooles buch empfehlen da
anfangen wo dann der jungs ist bohlen
gibt genauen von carlos ruiz zafón und
zwar im schatten des windes genau hammer
buch lese es wirklich ist ein roman
normalerweise bin ich kein roman lesen
normalerweise nur sachbücher
aber das ist wirklich wundervolles buch
kann ich eben nur empfinden schatten des
windes keine produktplatzierung es ist
wirklich ein bestseller übrigens ist
moora tatsächlich aber du auch nicht
warum hast du so wie es war
sie sagte ja
murats monats kontostand es pendelt
zwischen 4 und 8 100 euro weil ich eben
nie zuviel auszahlen weil wenn demokrat
mal ne karte hat dann der doping
dann hat sie eigentlich ab das heißt nie
so viel geld aufs konto dass die person
abbauen könnten mit vielen euro kommen
wieder bahn vielleicht gerade mal nach
stuttgart ich glaube die hat die frage
falsch formuliert was war das
peinlichste was dir wegen sally hier
geschehen ist es anders herum was war
das peinlichste was mir wegen moratti
geschehen ist jedes mal wenn wir
einkaufen waren im supermarkt das
dass mir das vorstelle dass könnt ihr
euch nicht vom wir laufen so zusammen
und dann sagt er immer irgendwas
peinlich ist aber so laut dass ich jedes
mal ab boden versinken und ich sage
immer dass timo vollauf ich sage immer
entschuldigung ist dass sally von salis
welt erstens weil ich erst hinterher hey
was machst du jetzt in der
fußballabteilung und es ist nicht so
lustig ist nicht genau und und wir haben
sofort wird das sieht sie mag es nicht
wenn ich sie in der öffentlichkeit ganz
laut durchs ganze einkaufszentrums etwas
passiert wenn ich im einkaufscenter zell
ihnen dann dann sehen das ganz ganz
vieles schnell ist hat es in waghäusel
genau und ein fehler murat sah deswegen
sagt sally müssen wie sally von salis
welt die vorträge
ich muss das machen dann ist das erste
was trinkt er ist mir auch manchmal
guckt ja darüber wie ich reagiere und
vor allem wie andere reagieren
ach gott in school war mal wir waren mal
national keine werbung machen waren
discounter ja und dann dann habe ich hab
ich es mir dann habe ich es mir also
jemand und dann hat die asa die
angeklagte sagte ich wollte gar nicht
sagt und ich weiß wer er sei es war das
ist wie ein alter das ist allerhand
bekommt morath immer instagram
nacktfotos von frauen männern die
website kurzem noch weidlich
fernakademie gezeigt ja ja ja ich kenne
die schweren seiten hatten jedoch auch
bei mir schreiben immer nur frauen bei
mir auch okay ist kein aufruf dass
männer schreiben sollen aber es ist aber
es sind diese spam seiten also ich
bekomme keine ich finde immer das stimmt
oftmals nicht was man so hört man
irgendwie so dass daten was weiß ich war
es an einem dran und nur schlimme sachen
also ich bekomme eigentlich keine
wieso bekomme ich keine nacktbilder
anderen menschen damit kann der kunde
haben richtig gehört
sie haben ich mache ja nicht bitte ich
werde mich vor lachen bietet macht es
nicht da muss jetzt hat sich überlegen
wer seine lieblingsschauspielerin ich
glaub du magst demi moore nein deutlich
fox nicht ich sagte nein
jessica alba nein jetzt habe ich dir so
viel schöne frauen genannt charlize
theron
wie sieht ihr aus guten film monster an
schaltet für monster ein cooler film
übrigens ähnlich cool also es hat ist
kein genuss film aber ist ein richtig
cooler film monster mit charlize theron
und ist nostalgie letzte frage ist seine
traumfrau
es muss doch die antworten das sagt ja
gut ist es auch erklärte ok da sind wir
der frage wundert dann geht es weiter
mit unserem pralinen ja
prodi was ich höre die pralinen drin
lassen ich habe deswegen denkt nein das
mache ich später für die ergonomische
höhe wahrscheinlich gerettet
deswegen meine größe ist noch nicht so
arg unterwegs ist dann passiert dass die
kugel mal geklebt aber das macht nichts
mit seiner hunde nicht lassen
so sind jetzt schön gefroren wie ihr
sehen könnt und jetzt nehme ich einfach
noch ein bisschen kuvertüre zum
verschließen die kommt jetzt hier
einfach in so einer schmelz schale
das wasser habe ich bereits kochen
lassen gab es vom hätte darunter
genommen und jetzt einfach warm
schmelzen
das könnt ihr auch noch kopf machen die
normalen gehen auch ja oder auch in der
mikrowelle wird auch so wenn jetzt ist
dann habt könnt ihr jetzt entweder mit
einem löffel zum beispiel die schokolade
darauf geben und verschließen oder in
kleinen spritzbeutel oder gefriert geht
auf genau
also müsse das ganze werkzeug sein zitat
ja haben wir machen partner weiter
gestärkt werden
mini spritzbeutel naja wie die babys
nehmen sich harvey spritzbeutel süße
schokolade sollte jetzt auch nicht so
heißt sein sollen danach hand wieder
schmerzen können
da wäre ganze beute geschmolzen
das machen ja ich alles wichtig ist wird
es auch gemacht hat sich vor kurzem
einen verschluss weil ich kenne ich gut
aus mit spritzbeutel weil ich habe dem
über 80 quadratmeter oder laufende meter
wie auch immer fugenmörtel gespritzt mit
dem spritzbeutel manchmal schließt ist
dann einfach so mit seiner klammer
modell vor allem für ungeübte ganz gut
weil also ich drehe hinten zu und nimmt
so aber für murat führt das zu machen
jetzt war eine kleine spitze abschneiden
genau und jetzt ist aber wichtig dass du
hier guck mal ist nämlich das ist
es ist nämlich nicht wichtig dass es gut
aussieht sondern einfach dass es richtig
verschlossen ist und damit später die
dem spritzbeutel wirklich empfehlen das
geht mir gut ich mache das schon damit
der joghurt dann herauskommen kann es
aussieht hätte es macht sogar spaß
gesehen und dann geht es auch richtig
schnell
also wenn du also perfekt die fotos
haben deshalb jetzt mache so wichtig
sagt er das muss einfach zu sein damit
die füllung nicht rauskommt ihr könnt in
berlin kurs auch mit eurer freundin
machen
hier ein kleiner macht selber klar nein
nein doch mal selber ausbilden ja ich
spiele abkommen geht ihren streit so
egal wie es jetzt machen würde
es würde ihr nie genügen ja doch gar
nicht erlaubt wenn mir das alles viel zu
viele gerade arbeite ich möchte ganz
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin eher der typ
der das 4 0
tom haak steak wendet unfertig das geht
mir auch die zu langsam im tourismus
wie lange ich hier viel spaß macht sich
so schnell so auch schön aussehen doch
perfekte bilder
das war jetzt gerade cool dass ich ein
bisschen mut
[Musik]
wenn sie dann verschlossen sind kommen
sie noch einen gefrierschrank oder
kühlschrank damit die show gerade fest
wird die schokolade hier wird temperiert
das heißt zuerst mal zwei drittel auf
dem herd erwärmen also im wasserbad
schmelzen lassen unternehmen und dann
das restliche drittel dazu damit sie
keinen großen genau
außerdem sehr sehr hochwertige
schokolade dann da ist es wirklich
einfacher so halten kaufen unsere
leckere schokolade
es sieht wundervoll aus schön glänzend
da kann ich nicht weg stellen
das ist der grund warum ich dir keine
blumengeschenke sprechen der blumen dann
jetzt gefriergetrockneten werden und
kokos ist jetzt zerkleinern genau bei
dem müsst ihr aufpassen weil die sind
richtig teuer aber auch in der
babynahrung abteilung genau die sind so
teuer wenn man halt vielleicht wenn die
gefriertrocknung ist kriegst du
vielleicht aus einem kilogramm himbeeren
vielleicht gerade mal 100 gramm
zusammenwachsen
deswegen sieht euer ja mal eben ins
wasser entzogen
genau so das thema kurz den mixer 12
[Musik]
ich stehe
ich glaube reich
ich stehe das liebes rot gut gefällt die
farbe das richtig wohl nachdem nach
erdbeere und kokos arena und kokos was
ist es ist wahnsinnig stolz die pralinen
hall
ihr habt welche okay wir machen jetzt
partner arbeit wünschte er das
schmuddelige machen oder rsv wanne
ich mag das schmuddelige voll das habe
ich mir gedacht ja weil ich mache mir
die hände schmutzig und das ist jetzt
wirklich partner arbeitet als praline
ist ex partner work warum fliegt ein
wir haben eine ratte morata in einem
monat eine ist weg 30 wie ist ja okay
okay er einfach ein bisschen schokolade
in die hand das wird schon
das ist schon erotisch jetzt also dass
ich mich schon zu viel
mama meter ab jetzt abschalten haben wir
bitte meine mutter jetzt zu schaut jetzt
die kugel nehmen darin rollen und du
hast saubere hände und deswegen nimmst
dem teller und schüttelt den so damit
die sich komplett damit ummantelt
spätestens jetzt sollten wir vielleicht
abschalten weil es vielleicht letzten
judenfrei ja jetzt schon sich kleine
aufgefallen dass hier gerade keine
werbung in den ganzen video eingeblendet
wurden weil alle gesagt haben kolo
valley creeks ich weiß doch bisher
schneller machen damals so wirklich
komplett umwandelt genießen neben so
viel zuschauer manchmal schnell darf ich
sie nachher die hände sauber machen
in diesem moment nicht warum man
pralinen mit einem partner machen sollte
ist es voll cool jetzt weiter
minute zumindest den teil auf den sauber
aber
ist diese so ein bisschen rollen ok hat
die mutter und rollen wenn sie noch
machen
ich weiß doch schon jetzt können sie
heraus dass ich weder weiter schmeißen
kann also ist liebeskugeln und mein gott
sie kommen begriffe ich mache mich voll
fertig ich habe angst dass jetzt die
körperhaltung was google aber hier
kinder dürfen noch nicht alleine und
also meine kinder nicht
[Musik]
sorgt eigentlich mehr fertig wir wollen
es noch alleine fertig gespielt oder bei
manchen gemeinsam genug aufnahmen
[Musik]
jetzt wird es die richtige konnte ich
meine haare nicht gerade gemacht nennt
sich das shooting david sein macht es
beginne aber schwierig wohl eingesaut
jedoch auch okay kann ich ja gleich
schon leicht ein wahnsinn kann es sein
dass gerade das in den augen gesehen
[Musik]
wenn ihr bis zu diesem punkt ankommt und
wirklich die praline so wie sie jetzt
aussieht schafft dann ist wahre liebe
dann ist es waren genau liegt euch er
war wirklich schön mit der minister auf
die baustelle
ich muss jetzt die romantik breche jetzt
hier abwarten hat spaß gemacht
magistrats gesetzt mein gott nicht egal
was ich sage ich assoziiere etwas
komisch ist damit auf jeweilige schnell
jetzt schnelles rezept gewählt und macht
es auf jeden nach über papieren
ach so der gehalt abreißt pflicht das
tonkabohne ist richtig ab rotieren
vielleicht doch nicht so baustelle
sondern sagt hier aber jetzt mal mit
ernst bei der sache
das ist eine richtig coole pralinen
füllung meiner mama es sind ja immer so
cremig und schwer aber davon kann man
nicht mehr essen
hier könnte ein schöner fokus könnte ja
auch haselnüsse neben finde ich jetzt
bin gelassen weil ich mag ich diese
kokosflocken willi hink dann über den
zähnen jedoch wie man ich würde dann ich
würde dann dinge und habe viel spaß
unterstützt die blumenhändler ganz ganz
wichtig in euer board daraus und
valentinstag machen ja wir machen den
valentinstag sektor aus dass hier
zuhause hilft die shades of prey titanic
und was weiß ich alles glauben sie war
mit ihrer besten freundin einfach machen
so ein mädels nachmittag mit single
ladies hören dass auch keinen walting
states wurde wir den kindern spanien
dominiert jemand nicht leiden können wir
machen das was ich im juni machte
nachher ein stück sinnfreien richtig
cool schmeckt bestimmt auch gute butter
einfach nur futter wirklich das gefühl
ich habe ja damals so fade berlin
wer cool viel spaß noch nachmachen habt
einen schönen valentinstag das wollte
ich das bild aufgeben aber egal ob einer
schönen valentinstag und das rezept
findet ihr natürlich in meiner efd war
schon super partner war es mit der gema
durch dick und dünn war dass ein spieler
auf mich
hektar wir gehen durch dick und dünn ich
habe nichts wir sind die konnte ich kann
mir meine mutter nun entschuldigung es
tut mir leid für die vielen zweibeinigen
wörter und redewendungen in dem ganzen
video machte mama ich liebe dich was
auch daran liegt dass erklärungen hat
eine mutter
ich liebe meine mutter ist noch mal
zusammen nein
[Musik]
asm aufnahme läuft ernsthaft
wir machen gerade eine asm er aufnahme
kommt schließt die tür ab hallo
ach du meine güte kommen wir professor
einmal nichts kriegen hier gebacken
[Musik]
so hatten
extra das motorrad hunger hat einfach an
den backen und plünderten läden
[Musik]